welcome everybody to part 9 of our
intermediate Python programming tutorial
series in this tutorial what we're going
to be talking about is more on
generators so a few tutorials ago we
talked about list comprehension and
generators but actually really just
generator expressions so if you remember
back back in the day we had a tutorial
where I showed something like this and
that was list comprehension and then I
was like but you can do the following
and it's actually now a generator and
it's literally just changing those
outside brackets to parentheses boom
generator or really a generator
expression the lazy way of creating
generators but there is another way to
create a generator and also I will just
remind you again the difference between
list comprehension and a generator is
that list comprehension is generally
going to be faster once that if once and
if that list is in memory but actually
building a list is actually kind of a
taxing process but in many cases or
maybe even most cases building the list
and iterating over the list is going to
be faster than a generator a generator
just will not use the same memory I will
use just a tiny tiny fraction of the
memory that list comprehension or a list
would use okay so we remember that
because we were there so now we're going
to be talking about is how to build your
own generator not a generator expression
a real generator so first of all
generators do not return things
generators yield things so maybe you've
seen something like this before like
let's say we're going to create this
generator function and we're going to
call it a simple gen or simple generator
and it's super simple all it does is
yield oh and then it's going to yield
hello
oh and then it's going to yield there
amazingly simple generator which we can
now iterate so for I in simple whoops
simple gen we're just going to print I
so we run that bring the interpreter
down and we get oh hello there okay no
surprise we could also make a lead you
know you can use lit list comprehension
to actually run over this if you wanted
and it would be fine it would build a
list that says oh hello there but you
could do that but basically this is the
same in terms of process and you're
saying something like for I in range
five or something like that right so
it's a generator so this is a really
simple generator function but it gets
the idea across now first of all I
wanted to show this purely because you
might actually see a generator in code
that you didn't write and if you don't
know what the heck that is that's a
problem but also there are times when a
generator is just where you might have
to actually write your own generator so
let's consider an example where it leads
a generator is better than a for loop or
even list comprehension so let's say you
have a program and you're going to try
to figure out the right combination so
you've got this this pseudo program you
could think of it almost as a password
cracker we're just going to rather than
using characters we'll just use numbers
like a number combination lock so let's
say the correct correct combo is going
to be equal to and you can use any
combination you want yeah just use any
combination you want probably don't
start with zero just so I can illustrate
fully my point but otherwise do whatever
you'd like so I'm going to use 361 now
with a for loop to figure out this combo
you might do something like this for C
one just for combination one in range we
know where it's a zero through nine so
range ten so for C one and then you
could check C one but you really don't
know if it's the correct combination to
a lock unless you do you try all the
letters at the same time so there's no
way for us to check that first letter or
that first character or in the case of a
lock that first number we don't really
have the answer we actually have to do
all of them at once unless we're like
a lock-picking pro or something but
we're not so now we're going to check
for c2 in range 10 and then again for c3
in range 10 now we have all the
combinations we're going to say we're
just going to ask if C 1 C 2 C 3 equals
correct combo we print found the combo :
and look at us we're going to use some
string formatting whoo C 1 C 2 C 3 great
ok so we can run this and sure enough we
find the combo everybody's happy we did
it all right but here's the thing is if
we say print found the combo let us go
ahead and come over here after the if
statement let's just for kicks let's
press print C 1 C 2 C 3 and let's run it
one more time waiting we're just going
to wait till it finds the combo and then
we're going to look what see what
happens found the combo it just whizzed
by and then here we go we're checking
all of the other combinations well
that's dumb okay whoops I took away the
cameras sorry anyway uh well that's dumb
so you might think okay well what we can
do haha we will break we'll just break
it run that and again found the combo
why did I get rid of that other print
statement I'll just write C 2 C 3 wait
for a found the combo it did break it
did break if we were able to go up there
we would see it broke but it was it
broke just this iteration of C 3 amongst
C 2 and C 1 so most it saved us like you
know 5 or 6 or I suppose you can save up
to 9 checks but other than that that
break did not save us anything so then
what we would have to do is maybe we'd
have to we'd have to insert break
statements at every at every level so
maybe we would be like okay we're good
programmers we were going to say found
combo equals false and
we're going to say instead you know if
found combo break and we're just going
to issue this at every level whoops
if found combo break and then yes found
combo equals true and we'll break now we
will run that it finds the combo and it
breaks and it breaks all the way through
because it sets found combo to true
breaks everything through and we're good
but boy was that a lot of code to make
that happen so now what we're going to
do is rather than using for loops what
we might do is let's make a generator so
instead let me just make some space here
instead we're going to say define combo
gen and then it's going to be basically
everything that we just saw but we're
going to just do for c1 in range 10 for
c2 and range 10 for c3 and range 10
yield c1 c2 c3 okay so we're going to
yield these and that's our generator now
what we're going to do is iterate over
the generator so for C 1 C 2 C 3 in
combo gen because that's our generator
so what do we know about the generator
we know that it's richer it does not
return things I was even said it returns
it yields things in a stream and that
stream can be ceased either through
logic in the generator itself or we can
stop it so for C 1 C 2 C 3 in combo
generator what are we going to do we
first of all we can print just so we can
see it
C 1 C 2 C 3 and then if this if that
equals our correct combo then we will
this print then we we found the combo
and we're just going to break boom one
break statement C 1 C 2 C 3 well just do
that good run it T's running notice it's
a little there it is okay found the
combo 3 6 & 1 here it is found the combo
and notice we didn't even make it to
this print statement everything's done
the the generator is no longer
generating anything we got our answer so
in this case we were able to actually
break out with a single break now in
terms of line count I'm pretty sure this
only saves us like two lines in reality
but if you ask me this is a lot cleaner
looking much more simple and it was much
easier to actually use our logic and we
got to use a generator which wasn't
wasting our memory in this case this was
a really simple task test but in many
cases you might find yourself trying to
do something like this and just just
getting outrageous like we did here like
this is just ugly so anyways that's a
little bit more on generative generators
how to write your own generator in this
case again oh wait I got rid of my first
example but the first example where we
just we just hard-coded what that
generator was going to yield you can
have a generator yielding anything you
want based on any logic you want so it's
really really cool to be able to do that
especially to be able to iterate through
stuff you also um we just happen because
we're just trying to generate some stuff
but you don't even you don't have to use
a generator in a generator and all that
so it's just meant to be a really simple
example but anyway if you do have any
questions comments
concerns whatever cool examples of
generators feel free to leave them below
otherwise I will see you in the next
tutorial